foreign
what's up Justin
hey guys it's it's exciting to talk to
y'all um my question is I've just gotten
um gotten on the I guess Dave Ramsey
plan just started listening um welcome
to the gang man
yeah
um and I I've ordered the The Total
Money Makeover it's on its way but
here's my question I'm 41. I'm a window
cleaner and I have nothing safe for
retirement and I'm just getting I I have
a really hard time
um
not putting money into the market
because I know the market is down and a
lot of people are scared to put money in
the market but I'm not and I'm looking
at this as a sale and it's like time to
buy and
um and I have nothing to say for
retirement and I'm worried about
retirement because I can't continue to
keep doing window cleaning until I'm 65
7. how much do you owe Brothers
um well I can bet
uh I have 133 on my mortgage and 24 on
my cars and made 14 in credit cards and
the thing is is I make enough money that
I can and we quit going out to eat we've
cut back I cut all my credit cards up
you know I'm cutting back on everything
so we're paying extra on everything
but I also have this extra 15 that I can
start throwing into the retirement and
that's where I'm I'm stuck I'll let
George dig into it off top of my head
you're not gonna get 28 return in the
market no matter how on sale it is
oh and so the 28 you're paying out one
way you're trying to earn back at
the market rate which is 10 or 11 or 12
percent
see what I'm saying
yeah yeah but everybody's saying like
the market is down like everybody around
you is broke brother and listen if if if
Dave came to me Dave has a lot of cars
he's got this one Corvette I'm not a
Corvette guy I like trucks more than
court but he's got his this Corvette
that's really old and it's incredible
let's say it's worth a hundred grand I
don't know what it's worth it's probably
worth way more than that and he came to
me and said John I'm going to give you
the deal of a lifetime I'm gonna give
this to you for fifty thousand dollars
that's the deal of a lifetime it is on
super sale and I don't have fifty
thousand dollars to buy it with
both of those things can be true you are
correct I am putting more money in in uh
retirement savings this year because the
market is on sale
and I think it's going to go a little
bit lower and I'm going to keep buying
I'm with you
you don't have the money to do that
because you owe thirty eight thousand
dollars in depreciating assets and
credit cards
what's your income Jace Justin
um roughly 95 to 100. okay
so you've got if on paper I'm seeing 38
000 in Consumer Debt
yeah so if you got real intense focused
you didn't invest the diamond to the
market and this year you said I'm
getting out of debt completely could you
do it by the end of the year
uh probably how much money do you have
in the bank in liquid cash
um just a thousand we've just gotten
started okay now you said I love
investing in the market but you also
said I've got nothing saving retirement
so those are two confusing sentences
have you been investing outside of
retirement or you love the idea of doing
it
no I love the idea of doing it because I
I've gone all these years of not
investing and it's like now I see but
why now the Market's been because down
in previous years
yeah I mean you've had it's just I guess
watching these tick tocks where
everybody's you know talking about you
know the Market's down it's a good time
to buy you know what's not cool on Tick
Tock Justin is someone saying hey guys
don't invest in the stock market just
start paying off your debt from smallest
to largest if I posted that on Tick Tock
today I would get about four views and
about a thousand comments of people
saying this guy's trash you need to
invest in the market and so it's all get
rich quick over there man
so turn off that input of social media
and let's turn up the fire on this debt
thing and say hey how much money would I
have to invest if I had no payments in
the world and I had a huge emergency
fund and I could breathe easy sleep
better at night and now I can start
really investing
and so one year from now you'll be there
investing in the market but right now we
have a priority of getting rid of this
debt and having money in the bank I also
I also am going to send you
um Ken Coleman's get clear assessment
it's very calm people to wake up in
their 40s and 50s and realize oh I can't
do this manual labor job in indefinitely
at some point this comes to an end I
think you're wise to start thinking what
what might that look like so hang on the
line here we're going to send you a copy
of the get clear settlement assessment
you can start asking yourself and your
family the question when we're out of
debt and I can do anything what would
that look like